homer plessy was born free in new
orleans louisiana on march 17 1863
just three months after president
abraham lincoln signed the emancipation
proclamation
plessy's father died when he was only
six years old but he never wanted for a
strong male figure in his life
victor dupart his stepfather filled that
role admirably
dupart made a good living as a shoemaker
and plessy thought he could do the same
so he took up the trade
but unbeknownst to them
theirs was a dying profession
in 1883
yon ernst matt zelliger a black inventor
born in modern-day suriname
patented a machine that could attach a
shoe's leather upper
to its sole
enabling mass production of footwear
just one of matt zelliger's shoe lasting
machines
could produce as many as 700 shoes per
day
it wouldn't be long before handmade
shoemaking was obsolete
du park was also a community activist
he was heavily involved in black civic
life in new orleans
championing freedom rights for people of
african descent through his leadership
in local masonic organizations
his stepson followed suit
in 1887
plessy became vice president of the
justice protective education and social
club which focused on educational reform
in the crescent city
in 1888
plessy married louise bordenave
the newlyweds found a place to live in
the historic treme neighborhood located
just north of the french quarter treme
was the oldest black community in new
orleans and the soul of the crescent
city
treme pulsated with energy especially at
night in the storyville section
african-american musicians blended
styles and sounds mixing blues ragtime
west african drumming rhythms and
european classical music chords to give
birth to jazz
america's most original sound
living in treme the plessies experienced
the color line differently than african
americans in many other places
to be sure new orleans was still part of
louisiana
scores of black men have been massacred
just 200 miles away in colfax in 1873
but new orleans had a long complex
history of race relations stemming from
its french colonial roots
the color line in the crescent city was
more flexible
after emancipation and in some cases
before
various people of african descent
attended racially integrated schools sat
where they wanted on trains and
streetcars and married whomever they
pleased
but that was changing
and it was changing quickly
the hayes tilden compromise of 1877
which completed the democrats return to
power
together with the supreme court's
opposition to congress's efforts to
protect the civil rights of african
americans
emboldened southern lawmakers to pass
sweeping segregation ordinances
as a way to reassert white supremacy
the new laws required separate
accommodations for african americans and
whites
they segregated everything from
hospitals to cemeteries touching black
life from the cradle to the grave
almost overnight
the system of mutually reinforcing
segregation laws and social customs
known as jim crow
took shape
the louisiana state legislature passed
the separate car act in 1890 requiring
separate railway carriages for the white
and colored races
although the statute stipulated that the
separate train cars had to be identical
the reality of segregation was that
african americans always received less
than whites
always
the new wave of white supremacist
legislation
disturbed blacks in the bayou state
tremendously
african americans understood that the
freedom rights they had fought so
desperately to achieve were at high risk
of being completely erased
in new orleans a group of black civil
rights activists formed the citizens
committee for the express purpose of
organizing a test case
to challenge the
constitutionality of the state's
separate car act
the plaintiff
was homer plessy
on june 7 1892
plessy entered the press street depot in
new orleans and purchased a first class
ticket for the east louisiana railway
number eight train
bound for covington louisiana
about a two hour ride away but plessy
never intended to leave the city
he intended to get arrested
after boarding the train plessy sat in a
white only car
in appearance
homer plessy looked white
but he wasn't
not completely
his paternal grandmother was a free
woman of color who married a frenchman
who had fled haiti in the 1790s during
the islands revolution
plessy's other grandparents were of
mixed racial ancestry making them
creoles and making him according to the
racial pseudoscience of the day
seven eighths caucasian and one eighth
african
as a result when he sat in the white
only car
he violated the state's segregation
ordinance and was subject to arrest and
fine
to put it plainly
he wasn't white enough
he had one too many drops
of african
blood conductor of the train
knew that plessy was african-american
he also knew what plessy was planning
having been alerted in advance by the
railroad company
like several other railroads the east
louisiana opposed the separate car act
company executives believe the law was
unnecessary
their trains had been operating on an
integrated basis without any problems
for years
they also believed that the law unfairly
burdened them
with the unnecessary expense of having
to add additional cars to their trains
even when there were not enough
passengers to fill them
complying with jim crow
which got its name from a popular 19th
century minstrel song character
required public performances of
ritualized customs
to demonstrate acceptance of segregation
laws
and acknowledgement of the superior
social status of white people
challenging jim crow required public
performances too
civil disobedience a favorite weapon of
the week
involved publicly refusing to comply
with segregation laws and customs in
order to draw attention to their
unfairness and to test their
constitutionality
when the conductor of the number 8 train
bound for covington approached plessy
the shoemaker knew he would be asked if
he was colored
at the same time the conductor knew that
plessy would answer yes and refused to
move to the colored car
a private detective hired by the
railroad knew what both would say
he was there to arrest plessy and whisk
him off to the parish jail of new
orleans
everyone
performed their part
lawyers for the citizens committee
bailed plessy out and stood with him as
orleans parish criminal court judge john
howard ferguson found him guilty of
violating the separate car act
plessy's conviction created the
opportunity that the citizens committee
wanted
it allowed them to challenge the
constitutionality of the state's
segregation laws
the group's lawyers immediately appealed
the conviction to the louisiana state
supreme court questioning the
constitutionality of the statute on the
grounds that it violated the 14th
amendment's guarantee
of equal protection under the law
but the court rejected their argument
it saw no problem with state mandated
segregation and upheld plessy's
conviction
undeterred the lawyers took plessy's
case to the u.s supreme court where they
argued that the only effect of
louisiana's separate car act was to
perpetuate the stigma of color to make
the curse immortal
incurable and inevitable
on may 18 1896
the supreme court handed down its
decision in plessy versus ferguson by a
vote of seven to one
the court ruled against homer plessy and
affirmed the constitutionality of
state-imposed racial segregation
the majority held that the architects of
the 14th amendment did not intend for it
to abolish distinctions based on color
or to enforce social equality
they also maintained that the existence
of segregated schools and
anti-miscegenation laws evidenced the
legality and legitimacy
of jim crow
finally
they insisted that segregation laws did
not stamp african americans with a badge
of inferiority
and if african americans felt that they
did
it was only because they chose to put
that construction on it
for the court
as long as separate accommodations were
equal
everything was fine
but separate of course
was never equal
justice john marshall harlan the great
dissenter
delivered his most famous minority
opinion in plessy versus ferguson
born into a prominent family of kentucky
enslavers
harlan chose the north over the south
during the civil war
and protecting black civil rights over
propping up white supremacy
in plessy versus ferguson
in his descent harlan wrote
the white race deems itself to be the
dominant race in this country
but in view of the constitution in the
eye of the law there is in this country
no superior dominant ruling class of
citizens
there is no caste here
our constitution is colorblind he
asserted
and neither knows nor tolerates classes
among citizens
turning his attention to civil rights
harlan wrote
the humblest
is the peer of the most powerful
the law regards man as man
and takes no account of his surroundings
or of his color when his civil rights
as guaranteed by the supreme law of the
land are involved
harlan later predicted that the court's
ruling would prove to be quite as
pernicious
as the decision made in the dred scott
case
and he was right
but it took more than half a century
before the court acknowledged its
mistake
back in new orleans
the citizens committee shared justice
harlan's dismay and disappointment
the group's attorneys had offered sound
legal and strong moral arguments
but none proved persuasive enough
for the majority of justices for whom
racial discrimination was not only
acceptable
but expected
before moving on to other battles
the committee issued a final statement
about their effort
they wrote
in defending the cause of liberty
we met with defeat
but not with ignominy
with his appeals exhausted homer plessy
paid the 25 fine levied against him by
judge ferguson for violating the state's
separate car act
he lived a quiet life after that
since shoemaking was no longer viable he
found work over the years as a laborer
warehouseman clerk and insurance
collector
when he died in 1925
just two weeks shy of his 62nd birthday
his case continued to serve as the legal
precedent guiding all race-related
jurisprudence
plessy versus ferguson
was a critical development in
african-american history
the court's separate but equal doctrine
provided southern states with
constitutional cover
as they passed a profusion of
segregation ordinances during the first
few decades of the new century it also
provided northern states with a
rationalization for continuing
discriminatory policies in housing
education employment and policing
plessy marked the beginning of the jim
crow era
a period bounded by the 1896 ruling and
the 1965 voting rights act
during these years legal segregation and
disenfranchisement defined the
parameters of black citizenship and
circumscribed african americans
unalienable rights of life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
but plessy was more than a starting
point for a new historical moment
it was also an end point
the culmination of a concerted effort on
the part of white southerners to
exercise total authority over african
americans and ability they had lost when
slavery was abolished
the story of jim crow therefore
doesn't begin with plessy
but rather with the political movement
that swept across the south during the
last quarter of the 19th century
this movement which plessy affirmed laid
the groundwork for white supremacist
rule in the south
jim crow
like slavery was about power
the power to control black workers
abolition robbed white southerners of
the tools they had relied on to keep
black labor yoked to the land
but it did not disabuse them of their
enslavers mentality
which fed their sense of entitlement to
what black workers produced
the persistence of an enslaver's
mentality led white southerners to
develop a variety of mechanisms for
controlling black workers
sharecropping quickly emerged as one of
the most effective tools in their
arsenal
over time
sharecropping looked more and more like
debt peonage which involved employers
compelling workers to pay off a debt by
working until the debt was cleared
although debt peonage had been outlawed
by congress in 1867
by the time the supreme court handed
down the plessy ruling
it was widespread in the south
and the system trapped more than just
sharecroppers
many black men women and children were
arrested on bogus charges such as
abusive language reckless eyeballing
trespassing and vagrancy
and convicted by corrupt justices of the
peace who were working in concert with
local police
the fine for the alleged crime might be
small
perhaps a dollar fifty
but court costs and fees were exorbitant
often totaling more than fifty dollars
which was well beyond most everybody's
means
to recover what they charged
county and state officials
leased those they had just convicted
sold them really
to employers in the market for
inexpensive disposable black labor
those who came calling on county
courthouses included plantation owners
as well as agents for railroad companies
and the extractive industries
such as iron ore mining companies in
birmingham alabama and turpentine farms
in north florida
while the cost of leasing a prisoner was
cheap convict leasing was big business
starting in the 1880s it created a
financial windfall for local and state
governments
once leased
african americans had to work off the
cost of their purchase
a term that could last many months or
even years
but living conditions in convict labor
camps were dreadful and working
conditions were even worse
survival was a matter of chance
25
of the nearly 750 county prisoners who
wound up in birmingham mines between
1894 and 1896
died
that's a higher mortality rate than the
middle passage
by all accounts convict leasing was just
a different kind of slavery
segregation
was another mechanism that white
southerners used to control black
workers but they didn't invent it
they adopted it
from the north
new york city segregated streetcars in
the 1850s
compelling black riders to move to the
rear of public conveyances and give up
their seats to white passengers
or suffer discourteous treatment at the
hands of conductors and passengers
and possibly arrest by the
police boston segregated public schools
even earlier than that
and ohio passed laws in 1807 to regulate
the behavior of free blacks
that presaged the black codes that
southern states tried to implement after
the civil war
but white southerners
took racial segregation to the extreme
not only did they separate blacks and
whites on streetcars and at schools
but also at hospitals job sites parks
stores jails restrooms churches and even
cemeteries
if there was a way
to separate people by race white
southerners figured out how to do it
segregation though
was never about separating the races
just for the sake of keeping black
people and white people apart
if that was the goal
it failed miserably
because the color line was extremely
porous
african americans and whites
intermingled in all aspects of life
both in public and in private
these interactions
were just never on an equal footing
whites routinely adjusted the color line
to avoid inconveniencing themselves
although train depots had separate
waiting rooms for black and white ticket
holders
a black woman
caring for a white child
could sit in the more spacious and
comfortable white only holding area
without garnering a second glance
so long as her white charge was with her
in this instance the color line was bent
so white families specifically white
women
would not have to suffer the
inconvenience of being without their
black domestic worker
while waiting for a train to arrive
segregation
helped control black labor by regulating
black behavior
despite what the supreme court said in
plessy
segregation did confer a badge of
inferiority
by stigmatizing blackness
it justified discriminatory treatment if
african americans didn't deserve to ride
in the same railroad car eat at the same
lunch counter or attend the same school
then they didn't deserve equal pay
or a fair share of what a crop sold for
at market
white southerners protected the new
social system of segregation
and the new debt-based labor
arrangements by disenfranchising african
americans
starting with mississippi in 1890
every state in the former confederacy
over the next 20 years rewrote its state
constitution to include provisions that
stripped african americans of the vote
to get around the 15th amendment which
forbade denying people the right to vote
because of their race
white lawmakers used race neutral
language to hide their intent
alabama rewrote its state constitution
in 1901
adding several measures designed to
nullify black voting rights that never
mentioned race
the new stipulations included
a cumulative poll tax which mandated
payment of back taxes before a person
could register
a requirement that impoverished african
americans simply could not meet
they also included a literacy test which
disqualified the high percentage of
african americans who were unable to
read or write because they were denied
access to schools
the impact of disenfranchisement was
felt immediately
one year before alabama's new
constitution
lowndes county alabama had more than
five thousand black registered voters
five years later the county had only 57.
just as devastating
were the collateral consequences
african americans lost their say in who
represented them
making it possible for all manner of
racially discriminatory laws to be
passed they also lost the right to sit
on juries because courthouse officials
used voter registration roles to create
lists of potential jurors
excluding african americans from the
jury pool
was especially harmful
because lady justice removed her
blindfold when all white juries sat in
judgment
of african americans
white southerners enforced the spate of
new discriminatory laws and customs
the same way they maintained the
institution of slavery
through fear
and violence
sheriffs and their deputies used
heavy-handed tactics ranging from quick
arrests to savage beatings
to make sure african americans adhered
to the dictates of the color line
and ordinary whites did their part too
rebuking african americans verbally and
physically
for even the slightest breaches of
segregation law and custom
lynching however
was the ultimate enforcement mechanism
whites lynched more than 1 000 african
americans during the last decade of the
19th century
two people a week
every week for 10 years
these murders
were not secret affairs conducted in
darkness by masked men
they were public spectacles
newspapers frequently advertised the
events days in advance so that white
people could gather for the hanging or
burning
and when the brutal business was done
a select few walked away with a piece of
human remains as a keepsake
and for those unable to snatch a
dismembered body part photographers
created postcards of these ghastly
gatherings for people to purchase as
souvenirs
these were bleak days for african
americans
what poet and playwright james weldon
johnson described
as days when hope unborn
had died
despite the resurgence of white
supremacy
african americans in the bustling
seaport city of wilmington north
carolina held on to the gains they had
made after emancipation and built a
thriving black community
they fellowshipped together in churches
bonded with one another in fraternal
organizations and cared for each other
through benevolent societies
they worked as professionals in
government banking and newspaper
publishing
as skilled artisans in industry
and on maritime crews at sea
and they participated in politics
voting into office black and white
republicans
but much of what they gained was wiped
out
on november 10 1898
by a mob hell bent on reestablishing
white supremacist rule
four months
wilmington's white elite
led by members of the democratic party
had been conspiring to get rid of the
city's republican office holders
they feigned outrage and incredulity
about an editorial in the daily record a
local black newspaper published by
alexander manley
manley had called out white men for
attempting to justify lynching
by saying they were only trying to stop
sexual assault on white women by black
men
when white people knew that the main
perpetrators of sexual violence were
white men
and the primary victims
were black women
two days after wilmington voters elected
a predominantly republican municipal
government
an armed white mob
easily numbering over one thousand
marched on manly's office fully
intending to lynch him
the men at the head of the mob were not
rogue actors but leading lights in the
community
such as former democratic congressman
alfred moore waddell
manley knew
his life was in danger
and fled the city well before the
rioters arrived
but that didn't stop the mob from
destroying his printing equipment and
setting his office on fire
it also didn't stop them from rampaging
through the black community
killing as many as 60 african americans
but the mob's work
was not yet done
they ordered the legitimately elected
republican members of the municipal
government to vacate their offices and
abandon the city under penalty of death
fearing for their lives
some 20 black elected officials and
civic leaders joined manly in exile
in their absence
white supremacists
took their seats
with the head of the mob
former congressman alfred waddell
seizing the mayor's office
the coup
orchestrated by democrats had succeeded
white supremacists installed a new
government and state authorities
recognized it immediately
the impact of the armed overthrow of the
wilmington municipal government would be
felt for generations
some 2100 african americans were forced
to leave the city to save their own
lives
many never returned weakening the social
networks and institutions at the heart
of the black community
black participation in government ended
and wouldn't resume until federal voting
rights protections were put in place in
the 1960s
black economic activity steadily
declined
as black businesses were forced to close
and black workers faced heightened
employment discrimination
and black schools teachers and students
suffered from decreased funding from the
lilly white government
resulting in a marked decline
in the black literacy rate
the wilmington massacre
was not an anomaly
white mobs burned black communities
murdered african americans and
dispossessed black people of their
property in pierce city missouri in 1901
springfield illinois in 1908 east st
louis illinois in 1917 elaine arkansas
in 1919
tulsa oklahoma black wall street in 1921
rosewood florida in 1923 and detroit
michigan in 1943
rather than an aberration
the wilmington massacre was illustrative
of the moment
the wilmington massacre was also
representative of the anti-black
anti-democratic political movement
sweeping the south
following the haze tilden compromise
white southerners ratcheted up their
efforts to disenfranchise african
americans
coming together despite significant
class differences
small white farmers had grown
distrustful of the fiscally conservative
plantation elite
who looked suspiciously at them for
entertaining the idea of forming
political alliances with black farmers
but in the end
white southerners coalesced around the
idea of stripping african americans of
the right to vote
they chose white supremacy
over democracy
the wilmington massacre
was what homer plessy was trying to
prevent
he challenged louisiana's separate car
act not only because it was unfair and
unjust
but also because he knew
that segregation stamped african
americans with a badge of inferiority
and being marked as less than white
subhuman even
provided a justification for
disenfranchising african americans and
worse
using violence to regulate black
behavior and control black labor
homer plessy was not alone
in trying to prevent atrocities like the
one that happened in wilmington
african americans across the country
organized to stop these outrages
their activism took many forms from
streetcar boycotts to mass migration
their protest though
did not stop the rising tide of white
supremacy
since reconstruction
america had become less democratic and
more violent
but their challenges did pay dividends
their agitation set the stage for a
black cultural renaissance and laid the
groundwork for the civil rights movement
although it was hard to see
there was light amidst the darkness hope
amidst the despair
because african americans like homer
plessy
kept fighting
for freedom rights